finally it's time to defeat the Emperor
of Rusty Spoons and even though we have
a vaguely mean slash teasing sexual
Rapport I'll help you but only because I
need to save a character you've never
met let's go hey guys boy the plot sure
is moving fast huh was he listening the
whole time we're the three best friends
of all time I'm part of this too look
he's openly contemptuous of you so I'll
be nice even though it's purely out of
pity we're gonna get some spoons I love
spoons actually we're going to kill the
spoons but whatever I'm just a silly
little guy
he's dying all because he saved us from
that ledge after we killed the spoon guy
I'm just glad I got to help my best
friend I finally appreciate you now
because you saved my life and that's the
only reason at least I got my spoon
that's right my beautiful creature you
sure did no I got these spoon the spoon
of enchanting we could save your beloved
boat that got destroyed in the second
act of the movie no save this pathetic
creature instead okay you've grown as a
person I'm saved all thanks to my family
hopefully you're less annoying in the
sequel now that you're part of our Core
Group